so today's topic women are still
navigating the effects of the
male-dominated workplace is a year and a
half after the rise of the me2 movement
now that's according to a new study by
lenin org that's an organization
dedicated to helping women achieve their
goals
it found in these numbers are very
troubling sixty percent of male managers
say they are uncomfortable interacting
with women at work and that's up 32%
from 2018 workplace interactions that
men are nervous about include mentoring
socializing and having one-on-one
meetings with women no I read the
numbers in my mouth fell open shocking
what message does it send well we're in
a bad place so sixty percent of male
managers in the u.s. sixty percent are
afraid to have a one-on-one meeting with
a woman
my only surprise in all this is not 100
percent I'm surprised that they're
surprised men senior men right now are
nine times more likely to hesitate to
travel with a woman and six times more
likely to hesitate to have a work dinner
and the problem is that even before this
women and especially women of color do
not get the same amount of mentoring as
men which means we're not getting an
equal seat at the table and you know
it's not enough to not harass us you
need to not ignore us either even if we
take false accusations aside even the
perception even if I come to you for
dinner everything's fine
someone observing me think there's
something inappropriate that can halt my
career so even the hint of something
inappropriate happening is devastating
to somebody's career I think she's being
very dishonest and I just think it's
interesting that women demand empathy
and they demand understanding when
they're not believed for their
accusations but women cannot fathom and
cannot be empathetic towards men who
fear losing their career in their
livelihoods at the hint of impropriety
that just blows my mind is that you
expect empathy but you cannot understand
why men would be afraid right ladies you
like going to parks you like seeing kids
like coochie coohcie as a man I can't do
that no because the way society views me
is predatorial
that's a fact if a strange kid runs up
to me he's like hi hey you catch me
entrepreneurship I'm running that's
Karen and I'm not even being facetious
I'm being dead a serious
that works at a kindergarten as cute a
man that works at a kindergarten that's
weird and you know the way or BOTS
people view a boss having a dinner with
his female co-worker who's below him
they view it as predatorial in that same
sense and it's unfair but that's the
world we live in and unfortunate that
means there's consequence for you so we
want to find a middle ground we want to
find how to find solutions but until you
understand us we're never gonna find it
the reason why this troubles me so much
is that if men are doing the right thing
and they're behaving appropriately they
don't have to worry about any of this
they don't have to worry about being
accused no that's not true does it
matter what we do right or wrong you
could be right
but what matters is really the
perception of the person forget
perception of the talk perception there
are crazy [ __ ] people out there there
are people who will accuse you for
enough there are women out there who
will beat themselves and say another man
there are women who will go to a mailman
and say you are sexual harass me because
you deliver mail to their IP here's this
great I was I already was going to the
office this guy walked into the office
when I was there and now here he is
parked out here great stop stalking me
right don't ever stop me again
yeah about what don't ever stalk me
again you do it you're crazy
is that right yes it is see you to the
camera that you're not stalking me I am
not stalking you I don't even know who
you are is that right
whether you did something or not it's
still your fault see if you get a cue
love something and it's not your fault
what people are gonna say what you put
yourself in a position that you know led
to that you are responsible even though
you did do nothing and she lied or a
person lied you're still responsible of
you putting yourself in that position
where there's smoke there's fire
garbage ass [ __ ] saying I can't stand
that thing I can't stand it or whether
there's smoke there's a vapor what where
the smoke there's a listen where there's
smoke there's a women telling the truth
and there there's fire that the man who
[ __ ] friction of the penis guilty I'd
like for you to treat me like the male
co-workers you have just because I'm a
woman I do not want to be treated
differently whoa whoa whoa what is this
posture why are your legs open change
your posture oh my god are you trying to
look sexy right now
don't put your knees lower you're don't
dance black people when they dance it's
sexy
are you staring at me right now do you
not know about hrs five-second rule if
you stare at me for five seconds you
know what that means 1 2 3 5 Harvey
Weinstein
Harvey Weinstein I can't wait for HR to
sandals you let me see your Spotify I
bet you have our Kelly on it don't you
answer me big G you spying yeah you
fired me another thing to consider is
that workplaces are a hotbed for
relationships and intimacy and flirting
ok one-third of all relationships are in
the workplace so people are engaging in
inappropriate behavior all the time and
for men who want to avoid gauging in
that realm sometimes the most sensible
way to do that is to avoid one-on-one
contact that could be misinterpreted as
flirting or as that because we all know
what happens in the workplace gossip
it's like it's a prerequisite to be in a
workplace the Job Description basically
you're gonna have to gossip a lot never
mind your own goddamn business whatever
I ask you to do a job you need to be on
Twitter and you need to be on your phone
I remember one time I went to the
bathroom and I came back and as I came
back a female co-worker came back at the
same time and people was like
[Music]
baby and you took a piss
no I took a big-ass Dookie [ __ ] I bet
ya so what why they think I was putting
it in her I was out of yourself stick it
in her Brown I was actually cleaning up
Bob Brown you know that over 50% of men
in the workplace don't know how to
compliment a woman why because the
bounds were what a problem with
compliment shifts from person to person
if I feel comfort with this person I'm
more leeway to this compliment if I find
this person attractive I may find this
cop learn more acceptable I may be
someone who hates all compliments so
it's very difficult to know hey they can
sexy today
[Music]
hey we're in the workplace
I'm not complimenting [ __ ] [ __ ] the
workplace [ __ ] in the world if I don't
know you I'm saying it [ __ ] no yeah I
don't know you I don't know you even if
you tell me a government oh this is my
jacket hmm thank you
so other than men not meeting with male
colleagues if they're worried about
meeting with because everybody knows
about gossip we occasionally there's
gossip in our industry surely men are
not crazy to think gee if I if I have a
one-on-one lunch or have this mentoring
meeting the gossip gets out of control
suddenly I'm having to explain something
when nothing was done wrong what other
steps then should men do if they're if
they have these concerns about what can
happen in a workplace where again they
have no control over what people when
tongues start wagging well look I'm with
Gayle you have to be able to have a
one-seat so she didn't hear what he said
she didn't reply to what he said she
said ah
sure he was here he was saying this is
what I'm afraid of it she went what
about me I mean what about me
I'm with her on one conversation and
those conversations can happen in rooms
with the doors open in a public
restaurant having a lunch or dinner I
don't really think you can get falsely
accused it doesn't matter when I throw
this [ __ ] laptop this was mark
Pearson was making his way back home
during a busy commute when he passed a
complete stranger in that split-second
his life changed forever after she
falsely accused him of sexual assault
well on Friday mark was found not guilty
and he joins us now alongside Erin
Pizzey who has been his avid campaigner
I mean I had the option not to say
anything my solicitor the duty solicitor
said you could either say no comment or
you could be fully cooperative which is
what I did because any normal person
would assume the common sense would
prevail they would look at the CCTV
footage which I had compared that with
what the woman was saying and conclude
that it was preposterous it was just
nonsense what she was saying
well she said claim that you sexy
assaulted her penetrative Lee for 2 or 3
seconds and this was followed she
insisted by a violent blow to her left
shoulder and since this has all come to
light and we've all seen the CCTV
footage it is impossible for that to
have happened totally contradicts what
she's saying
I was four months after that that you
were then phoned by a solicitor and he
said you're gonna be charged yeah and
then this is going to go to court that
was the worst day of my life so
do you understand that he was accused
and was literally impossible that he
could have touched her it's on camera
and he was still charged because in this
society and this belief her society even
if you do no wrong you can still be seen
as guilty people that say well false
accusations don't happen often
that's a misreported stat it's hard to
prove a false accusation is an actually
a false accusation a false accusation is
indicative someone who's intentionally
trying to lie and to prove that someone
is actually trying to lie it's very
difficult and so most of the time you
can't report these that's why the stats
are very misleading on me and also I
don't think people realize just how
traumatic a false accusation can be oh
when you are unjustly accused of
something it makes you angry to a point
that it's almost uncontrollable yeah but
ABBA
if we didn't nothing you're gonna be
calm and you're gonna be chill oh I'm
telling you man even eight years after I
was accused of something that never
happened I was never the same loser
person even after this person admitted
to having lied
I remember being angry because I lost
you know three four months of my life
under this cloud of like you know maybe
this person is evil that's what people
are saying about me and when it came out
that it wasn't true I was angry after
the fact I was angry that there was no
due process I was angry that I wasn't
shown any benefit of the doubt I was
angry at the person for wanting to
derail my life for whatever personal
reasons that she had and so I never
leaves even today when people bring that
kind of stuff up to me those feelings
still well up because if you know your
character and you know yourself to be a
good person then it's hard to know that
that's being questioned for no other
reason than someone said otherwise and
it makes it feel like everything is
fickle like these people who I thought I
could count on turned out I could count
on them at all and that's a hard thing
to live with so I would just tell people
to be cautious and to understand that
sometimes people have lived that trauma
I don't want to really live it or people
have seen their friends go through it
and they're like [ __ ] I don't want that
to me so I'm gonna avoid this contact
and that's a real feel that exists so
seemly I can understand that women are
justly afraid when they walk down the
street and you know it's late at night I
understand that fear wonder who's
walking behind you I'm empathetic to
that that you guys even if they didn't
do nothing you're still afraid that same
way when I'm alone with a woman I
understand how that can be
misinterpreted
and now I'm afraid even if it's not the
most logical solution it is still a real
fear that I have so I will just tell you
just think about that
now look ladies I'm empathetic to what
you guys are going through I am pathetic
too the fact that you know what it's
unfair that you guys aren't going to be
able to advance because you don't have
those one-on-one experiences or you
don't have that access to that
mentorship but we also have to have
honest relationship about the dynamic
between men and women how it's perceived
how men are perceived when they have
higher power and they have a wound
beneath them and how that can be
interpreted how that can negatively
impact Ben if you don't have that
conversation that men are not going to
sacrifice themselves or put themselves
into the formal positions just to be
able to help you out and it's unfair but
that is the reality because I the other
day most of us are about self
preservation that is the truth so we
have to find a way to undo a lot of that
social conditioning undo some of those
bad habits so that we can help women
move forward in the workplace and have
as much equal opportunity as possible
[Music]
you